très bien a pris ses quartiers d'hiver à
la maison c'est sur la table de salle à
manger qu'il prépare sa prochaine
maquette comme chaque fois elle ne
ressemblera que de loin aux modèles de
la boîte qui sert de base à sa création
ça c'est de la lui que j'ai récupéré
parce que bon bah disons que j'avais à
ces faits n'étaient pas trop loin et
comme de fait d'un mac est bon surtout
lourd améliorer tous là j'avais été
récupérée de l'alu couleurs couleurs
disons couleur aura peut donc la bomba
et je vais essayer de tout le quart est
né avec ses piètres et en plus mon
camion il a la couleur bronze et noir
vous accorder les couleurs aussi pour
réaliser une telle maquette patrice va
mettre deux mois en y travaillant
beaucoup travaillé le matin moi surtout
et à la lumière du jour
parce que bon les ongles sont pas les
mêmes et bon je travaille à peu près je
sais pas ils ont entre quatre et six
heures par jour parce que l'après midi
c'est repos le secret d'une telle
patience
la passion et aussi la compétition qu'il
a beaucoup pratiqué dans sa vie effet
les championnats d'europe
bon ça championnat de france championnat
d'europe pour moi c'est du courant je
suis connue ils ont à peu près partout
et je suis allé
en position dans les concours ma
position c'est en général dans les trois
premiers il suffit de suivre
l'australien dans sa caverne d'ali baba
le grenier ateliers pour s'en convaincre
allez les coupes bas c'est tout mais
métro fait que depuis je fais de
maquettes et les expos concours et donc
j'invite tous avaient des médailles
malheureusement les médailles bon vachon
dans une boîte dans le fond du but de
l'atelier
voilà c'est un atelier quiberon où il ya
toutes mes maquettes que j'entrepose
parce que bon je peux promettre non plus
par tous et bon coup je travaille
principalement je travaille à cet
endroit là donc là je lis mme jeu couple
je fais tout ce qu'il faut monter mes
maquettes et après un bon bain sur
l'autre côté j'ai mes plaques ma
collection de plaques américaine 40 ans
de passion ont débordé jusqu'au garage
où patrice range ses camions etc diorama
ces dispositifs de présentation par mise
en situation de maquettes où il donne
libre cours à son talent en recréant des
tableaux poétiques mettant en scène
c'est ma tête et qui lui ont valu eux
aussi de nombreuses récompenses